inflation and when most people talk
about inflation they're talking about
price inflation and that's just the
general increase in the level of prices
for goods and services and you probably
have a sense of that that every year in
kind of a normal economy things seem to
get a little bit more expensive although
not everything does but especially if
you look at something like healthcare or
the cost of education you definitely see
things getting more expensive every year
but one interesting question is how do
you measure it how do you measure
inflation and what the Bureau of Labor
Statistics does and this is actually the
most used measure of inflation they
create something called a Consumer Price
Index and the way they do it is that
they define a basket of goods and
actually a basket of goods and services
so what they do is they go and they look
at the average urban consumer and they
say what do they need in their life they
might need some housing they might need
some fuel some natural gas for their
home they need gasoline for their cars
they need energy in other ways they
might need some type of services they
might need transportation and they try
to write ooh come up with a basket of
all of the things that the average
consumer in an urban environment might
need and they figure out how much that
would cost them in year 1 and let's say
that in year one that it costs them $100
the actual basket of the CPI constructs
would not cost a hundred dollars but I'm
going to do this for the sake of
simplicity and they'll wait these based
on how much what percentage they think
people spend on housing versus fuel
versus services versus transportation
then they'll look at the same basket
each year after that so then they'll do
the same things housing fuels services
transportation and then this would be in
year two now and year two and let's say
that same basket costs one hundred one
hundred and two dollars
well then they'll say that the general
level of price and services for this
consumer went up by two dollars or went
up by the more important thing is by the
percentage by two percent so based on
this measure based on this basket of
goods prices went up by two percent or
you'll hear people on the news say that
the
inflation rate went up by two percent
now I want to clarify when inflation
sometimes talks to inflation in the
money supply so people talk about
there's just more money being printed
and often an increase in the money
supply is usually one of the factors
that is driving price inflation but when
most people talk about inflation today
they're talking about price inflation
they're talking about the increase in
prices they're not directly talking
about the increase in the money supply
now this seems like a pretty simple
thing to do but it's not as simple as
you might first think because think
about something like TV sets or
especially anything this technological
do you look at the same TV set that's
getting probably cheaper every year or
do you look at the average TV set that
the American household is having do you
look at the same computer that's getting
significantly cheaper every year or do
you look at the average computer every
year because then you'd actually be
looking at a different product so
there's actually a lot of things to
think about a lot of things how you
could weight this and there's been a lot
of controversy and and and when the
waiting's change it in different periods
of time but this is the general idea and
it's really just the best attempt to
figure out on average how much more
expensive or how much purchasing power
are we losing from one year to the next